you can only attract according to the
frequency that you're operating on
attraction is a secondary law the
primary law is the law of vibration
that's a that's a primary law of the
universe everything in this room is
moving
nothing rests this table's moving it
just appears to be still
the law of vibration decrees everything
moves nothing rests well when you think
you put you under a frequency you can
only attract what's on that frequency
you think about a person a lot just
concentrate on that person i'll phone
you
or you'll bump into them on the street
because you you're thinking about it
yeah the law of attraction takes over
you can attract to you what you're in
harmony with well when you set goals you
got to see yourself already there that's
called a mindset
a lot of people talk about mindset they
don't understand what it is they set
their mind on the frequency that they
have to be in to attract what they have
to attract
and that's how the government tend to
form you get emotionally involved you're
you're so intellectually and emotionally
involved
the only problem is you don't have it on
the physical plane
yet
but it will manifest
in time when we stop expecting things to
be the way that we
think they should be when we stop
forcing outcomes and when we start
allowing what is of the highest good to
be our only agenda our only intention
that's when the universe truly has our
back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop praying for
what we think we need and we start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest
good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what well how will
i get what is of the highest good but
how can i be open to what is of the
highest good how can i open up my
consciousness to release what i think i
need and get grounded in what is
possible and what is of the highest good
not just for me and my agenda but the
highest good for all that's the message
so you're doing everything right in that
you're
open to a spiritual practice you're
willing to grow you're showing up for
your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
doing that actually creates sort of a
manic manifesting vibration which is how
do i get that how do what am i what do i
do next got to do this thing next got to
do this thing next and that lacks the
belief system that i can be still and i
can allow
that's number one
number two being in the expectation of
what you think things should be is
another block to your manifesting power
and your super attractor power which is
what i call it because your expectations
are limiting the possibilities your
expectations are limiting the highest
good as this card says so when we start
to pray for what is of the highest good
rather than intend and pray for what we
think we need that's when the universe
can conspire with what it is that is of
the highest good for all
so ultimately what's happening is all
the doing doing doing is energetically
blocking
and all the expecting expecting
expecting is blocking the manifestation
as well because when you're in this
tunnel vision of expectation it should
be this way i should be further along i
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible in
this moment the creative possibility in
this moment the exciting potential in
this moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it
i want you to sit on your ass
i want you to stop doing doing doing
i want you to
start being
being
being which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbying yourself you said
i want to embody the feeling i want to
embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require
us to show up for our desires you got to
pick up the phone and then call the job
interview and you have to ask for the
date and you have to to do whatever it
is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel the power to manifest
is in
experiencing the
fullness
of the present moment
the undifferentiated fullness what jesus
called
life in its fullness
[Music]
in one of the translations
i want you to have life in its fullness
he said
and that is
not stuff is not referring to things
life in its fullness is an inner state
of being
it is to experience to know to realize
the beingness within you the i am
with this consciousness itself
that is life that is the fullness of
life in the words of jesus
the fullness of life
is to to ex to
realize that
so that
once you realize that and it is
consciousness
you you know yourself as consciousness
[Music]
once you know that
[Music]
then
[Music]
no future moment can possibly be better
but anything that can happen in the
future isn't adding on to
so if you bring
together if you have a vision in your
mind of what it is you want to achieve
or create or manifest
[Music]
and you bring this vision
into this sense of
still
fullness
[Music]
that you sense now
and you bring that together that is the
most powerful
creative tool the way that
it's usually expressed jesus expressed
it too he said when you pray for
something
believe that you already have it that's
but i think he probably used actually
slightly different words but that's how
it was written down
he said
he's
probably said feel that you already have
it
whatever it is that you want to have
that you think is going to be
you need to you need to feel already the
feeling that you know how do you do that
by feeling that which is beyond
the world of phenomena
out of which everything arises which is
consciousness
so when you know yourself as
consciousness
that's already the fulfillment tell us
about this belief
where does this
block of a belief come from
and how has it created such a strong
hold on each and every single one of us
well the belief is that we are separate
and that we are individual
and that all
that we consist of all that makes us up
is just a body and a mind and i think
the majority of people will consider
that they're a body and a mind
and the name that they've been given
and the story uh of their life and i was
born here and parents did this and i do
this for a living and siblings and the
story that we then cat we identify with
and carry around with us and and
and those stories the story it doesn't
matter what the story is it doesn't
matter how fabulous your life has been
it does not compare to who we really are
and so we have this belief that we are
limited
basically in a nutshell that we're a
limited individual that we're born and
that we die
and and that's kind of it and the truth
is we're we are so much more than that
we are certainly having the experience
of being an individual and we're
certainly having the experience having a
human experience but ultimately it is
not who we are and we were never born
and we never die
and
we are
if i were to sum up everything that we
are it's almost the opposite
to everything we strive to be
so we are all the intelligence that
there is we are all the beauty that
there is where all the happiness that
there is we are pure love without any
judgment whatsoever
um
we are complete and utter freedom
which is why freedom means so much to us
why we will fight and struggle to be
free
uh and so we and and we have total
knowing of absolutely everything in the
moment of knowing it we are infinite and
we are eternal
and that is what is actually
experiencing
this
particular form
and so we have a belief that we are an
individual that we're separate that
we're born and that we die
and
our mind reaffirms that over and over
and over again through all of its
thoughts and with everything we say with
every thought and every single thing
that we say and actually doesn't the
world affirm that over and over that was
that we're separate
um
but
we are unlimited
we are absolute perfection
and and i'm not talking about the name
or the ego i'm not talking about that
because we we all can see what egos can
get up to you know they can get
they can cause a lot of trouble
he goes why egos want approval they want
attention and they want to be right all
the time they judge all of the time and
so you know they're not they're not
something to to attach ourselves to and
to identify with when we are this
incredible being that is blissful
happiness
and so
um
and so we can
have a life
where we are living as an individual
human having an individual human
experience
but from the perspective of the infinite
being that we are
in which case we will never be touched
by negativity no matter what happens and
we will remain in lasting happiness no
matter what obviously you knew somewhere
inside yourself that you were destined
to be famous because i think it's really
a marvelous thing that visualization
thing you did do do you read about this
or hear this that you used to go up on
mulholland drive and park every night
and visualize seeing yourself as
yeah i would visualize uh yeah this is
where you were broken
right having directors interested in me
and people that i respected uh um
saying you know i like your work or
whatever that is and and uh i would
visualize things coming to me that i
wanted or whatever this was in like
85 yeah and i had nothing at that time
so it was like but it just made me feel
better it made me at that time all it
really was for me was kind of making me
feel better i would drive home and think
well i do have these things and they're
out there i just don't have a hold of
them yet but they're out there okay so
you would get this from what self-help
books or whatever yeah uh-huh self-help
section self-help section they've
renamed it the jim carrey wing
so didn't you write yourself a check i
heard that you did is that true i wrote
myself a check for 10 million dollars
for acting services rendered and i gave
myself uh five years
or three years maybe and uh
and i dated it thanksgiving 1995
and i put it in my wallet and i kept it
there and it deteriorated and
deteriorated and stuff and uh
and uh but then
just before
thanksgiving 1995 i found out that i was
gonna make 10 million dollars on i think
it was dumb and dumber maybe dumb and
dumber yeah yeah so you visualize
yourself
visualization works if you work hard
yeah well yeah that's that's the thing
you can't just visualize and then you
know go eat a sandwich when we talk
about
or think about the law of attraction
before we even consider that law and
several other corollary laws
when we talk about everything is energy
what does that really mean
right like
what does that really mean
and
when you think about you know we use
telescopes to look into outer space into
the cosmos
and we use microscopes to look deeper
into material things until
it all disappears anyway right
we can see electrons and protons
and muons uh and quarks
and leptons the very
fundamental building blocks
of nature of our body of plants of the
ocean of
everything in the
known cosmos
and
it appears
that everything is vibrating if you were
to look through these electron
microscopes you know deep into a plant
or even your hand although it appears to
be solid
um we see vibrating packets of this
thing we call energy vibrating packets
of something called quanta right
and so if everything is vibrating
then is it possible and this is a
dialogue right is it possible
that when you and i have
a thought
a positive one a negative one
a thought about something we want or
something we don't want right so it's a
thought a spark of
electrochemical activity
in the brain a thought we say you know i
want this i don't want that is it
possible let's just have a little
dialogue here is it possible
that since that thought
is a burst of electrical activity and
also releases a chemical that correlates
with that thought
is it possible
that
the
electrochemical
activity is vibrating
oscillating moving whatever you want to
call it at a certain frequency
that resonates or repels with certain
things in the physical world is it
possible if everything is
energy
how do you get into resonance
with what it is you want to
you know attract how do you get mentally
physically emotionally spiritually
in resonance
with the stuff that you want
instead of what you don't want here's
one of the biggest challenges
our brains are wired for safety first
emotional safety physical safety
financial safety first and so in order
to protect ourselves
our brain actually has to think about
where is there danger
like where could i get hurt and in
thinking about where you can get hurt is
it possible that
sometimes we're in a temporary or
permanent state of fear
and if we're in a permanent or temporary
state of fear is it possible that that
state of fear or uncertainty or
self-doubt
is actually attracting
resonating with the stuff that we don't
want
one of the keys to applying the law of
resonance
um is
getting your
mindset right the brain
right focused on what it is that you
want
getting your heart
right the emotions
aligned as well so it's head and heart
aligned also with what it is you want to
resonate with
and then there's another piece to it
that not a lot of people think about or
talk about and that's the gut
right the brain gut access is in
communication
with each other at all times and there's
a lot of research around you've got to
really follow your instincts right your
intuition your instinctual
feeling about stuff so you got to get
the head the heart and the gut aligned
and that is really the winning
combination
to be in a state of resonance if you are
in a tough financial spot maybe you're
struggling financially you've been
trying to start a business or a side
hustle
i've been there i know what this feels
like it's not fun for a long time i was
living on my sister's couch
and i didn't have much money it was
really stressful i remember this feeling
of being stuck
feeling like i was never going to make
any money and when i was focusing on
that feeling of i'm never going to make
this money i feel stuck i feel trapped
when's this going to happen feeling this
anxiousness this stress around it
it was really impossible for me to think
of creative ideas it was impossible for
me to
take action because i was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what i was having in that moment i
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is allowing me to stay
here for free so i have some time to
learn a new skill
i made a hundred dollars this day i
should be grateful for that not a
focusing on what i'm lacking or what i
don't have but what i am creating on a
daily basis and i started to ask
different questions around this time
like how can i be of service to other
people how can i add as much value to
someone else or what are my top skill
sets that i can use
to my advantage that no one else has
like what do i have i started writing a
list of all these different skills that
i had even when i didn't think i had
many skills i still wrote down a list of
the qualities i have of the skills from
the past that maybe i could apply to
right now and when i began asking those
types of questions i started attracting
the people who needed my skill sets and
services and i finally started to make
more money than ever before because i
was thinking about serving others i was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
i'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and i'll never make anything from
this situation i started focusing on how
can i add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can i serve them how
can i create for them how can i connect
someone to them that could help them
what can i do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
i think as zig ziglar said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what i started focusing on not
what i'm lacking but how can i give and
how can i add value to other people when
you focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect one
person helping another person how it
comes back around to you and if you've
ever felt this for yourself leave a
comment below of this feeling you've had
when you started adding more and more
value getting out of the negative
situation inside your mind and in your
body focusing outward on helping others
it's incredible the things you can start
to attract and manifest in your life
intention and attention
in the field of
infinite possibilities
is all that matters
intention and intention in the fill in
field of infinite possibilities
have the intention of what you want to
create
with the abundance you have
and then with that intention
go and
transcend
and when you transcend
you transcend to the source
and there are many ways of transcending
through music through
a walk in nature
through
poetry
through dance
through
whirling through meditation
through
play
and
through
collective
what i call collective
envisioning
collective envisioning when you have a
group of people who have a vision
together
when you have an open system
when you're
totally
transparent when
you invite
even absurd ideas
when you make unlikely connections
then something emerges and we call that
emergence so
create a group
for wealth consciousness
and if you create that group
and if you're transparent and if you
invite
unlikely alliances
if you have maximum diversity of people
from the arts from the humanities from
sciences
from
any field technology mathematics
whatever
and
you sit and incubate together
with
attention and intention then emergence
happens
just happens
and the emergence of
abundance in this case
with the proper
attention and intention and even
collective intention i know somebody in
new york who just raised 450 million
dollars
through crowdsourcing
um for creating a place
for um
spiritual
enlightenment
but this is how they did it
crowdsourcing
with
authenticity with sincerity
with integrity
and
with
joy i think it's science that
demystifies the mystical
and if you can combine a little quantum
physics with a little neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at possibility
and
if you talk about religion if you talk
about culture if you talk about
tradition even spirituality i notice
that you divide an audience but science
in a sense creates community so people
come
for all kinds of reasons and what i've
learned in the last year or so is that
what people really want is wholeness
because when we want something or in
separation or in lack right
and so when we started
experimenting with doing different
scientific measurements one of the
things we started to notice is that when
a person
somehow connects
to something greater
and that has a influence on their
nervous system
the side effect is that they feel so
whole
so rejuvenated in that moment so blessed
by life
in that moment from an inner experience
that it's impossible for them to want i
mean how can you want
when you feel whole right and so when we
started looking at heart coherence and
we saw this
tremendous
changes in the
people's ability to be able to sustain
a state of mind a feeling in their heart
for an extended period of time
we have data to show you could be sick
and do that you could be a vegetarian
and do that you could be a carnivore and
do that you could be rich you could be
poor it doesn't if you're skinny
overweight doesn't matter once you learn
that skill of self-regulation
and being able to
experience a greater level of wholeness
that if you can create from wholeness
instead of separation or lack
you can produce greater effects
on the nature of reality so
we came from singularity and in when
you're oneness or when your source
there's no separation between cause and
effect your thoughts create experiences
when you're in oneness we journey down
the density and now we're really
separate from source
and so the
what what happens between cause and
effect is called time
so we're here now
to prove to ourselves that the divine
lives in us
so why not practice
shortening
time or the interval between cause the
thought and the effect the experience
and when you start seeing something
appear in your life as a result of you
at cause
you start getting more kind more caring
more loving more conscious more present
because you feel more whole there's a
primary law called the law of vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
the body in a coffin is moving
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something like
if the body in a coffin wasn't moving
how would it ever change the dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in a notion
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall
it's not solid it only appears to be
solid or perception problem there you'll
see the wall moving right in front of
your eyes there's a particle of energy
and they're dancing right before your
eyes that's a lot of vibration the law
of vibration decrees everything moves
nothing rests we literally live in a
notion of motion
now this physical instrument we're
living in we call our body is a
molecular structure and it's in a very
high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station
when we activate brain cells we alter
the vibration in different parts of the
body i could not move my hand up and
down or my arm up and down without first
giving a message to my brain to do that
well the brain
activates cells in the body it sets up a
vibration in the body
the
vibration that the mind and body are in
is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in the
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you what's in harmonious
vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration
you're not going to get it but if you
can see yourself with it you know it's
coming to you you know it you know it's
only a period of time you're not quite
sure what the time is but you know it's
a period of time and bang that thing's
going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in
the vibration then called the frequency
you put yourself in the frequency that
you good your desires on
let's suppose i want to have a lot of
money we're just talking about money now
this is a lot of money relative to let's
say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i got
to mentally accept i've already got it i
don't let my bank account dictate that
i choose that
so choosing myself to see myself with
the good i already desire i'm on that
frequency now the trick is to stay on
that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results
they have the image in their mind
they're already reached the goal they
want they're already successful and
somebody else comes along and say well
you haven't got those results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it
do you see why we keep getting this poor
results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed everything's
already here if not in one frequency
certainly in another or not in one state
certainly in another we've got to get on
the frequency of the good that we desire
the basic thing that neville taught me
and a lot of this is from the teachings
of neville uh neville goddard who died
in the 1970s he
he basically said that
all of us have within us this amazing
capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life so
how we call it what what words that we
use we have to be able to say um you
know in the secret they say you get what
you want you know and what is missing
and what neville said and what what has
come to me and what i got from the i am
discourses and what i get from the new
testament which i read before i did it
is that you s you say
i will attract into my life what i am
not what i want and i am capable of
attracting all things that
that the source is capable of attracting
so
that's the difference it's like you get
what you are rather than what you want
so you want to become
you can't go around and ask these divine
beings
you know angels whatever you want to
call them who are right here all the
time
you can't ask them to help me out you
have to
you have to become like they are
that when you're when you become angelic
when you become a divine being yourself
when you are giving when you are serving
when you are in that place they will
come to you that's what happened to you
in india you then begin to see yourself
in everything that's what the daoda qing
teaches as well they call it your
original nature your original nature is
reverence for all of life gentleness
kindness and service towards others
that's lao tzu 500 years before the
birth of christ saying that's our
original nature yes reverence for all of
life gentleness kindness service towards
other giving offering serving and when
you get to that place where you no
longer have any judgment within you
towards any of god's children that means
no condemnation no criticism no judgment
towards anyone if enough of us get this
message over if enough of us get on
that's just what my mission is is just
to teach people that you are love you
are divine put that into your
imagination i am i am well i am happy i
am content i am fulfilled even if your
senses tell you that you're depressed
one of your people that called me when
we did a pre-interview on here said well
if i if i'm feeling depressed i'm
supposed to fool myself and say i am
feeling well even you can choose another
thought that's what i have absolutely
and it's like you don't say i am
depressed because if you say i am
depressed you connect with depression
and the universal source god whatever
you want to call it will align in such a
way to offer you whatever it is
yeah here's some more depression i am
unhappy i am depressed i am so by
placing into your imagination what you
want and assuming the feeling of that
wish is already fulfilled you go through
your life feeling that when enough of us
do that we will we will transform this
planet i'm telling you it can be done
eighty percent of you who use a vision
book or a vision board say
it changed me
i've told you about my vision board i
had it above my bed i wanted to get
married i wanted to go to africa and
here's a picture of my wedding was such
a here's a picture of me in africa
holding a lion that had been raised from
a cub with a family and it lived there
and it was amazing but i made these come
true i had that vision in my mind i held
that vision i'm
getting married i'm going on safari
and you're never given a vision without
an idea of making it real because what
you want wants you
what you are moving towards is moving
towards you have a vision or a dream or
a wish inside you
get it out of you
put it on paper look at it touch it
read it then you are making it real when
you can look at your vision write all
over your vision
write on it change it mix it up it's not
a dream
you're making it real your potential
expands as you move towards it this will
expand your potential
when you move your mind to a new
dimension it never moves back
never right i wish i dream right i am i
do i can i will i always
i always exercise i can
fit exercise into my life i am
a fit person
i always pick healthy food i can find
healthy food wherever i go i'm the kind
of person that makes eating well a
master priority i can i do i am i always
inspire your mind turn it on with
exciting words turn it on with exciting
images so here's
a vision folder the other thing about
this vision book is it makes you
accountable as you look every day the
pictures of someone
doing yoga
or eating fruit you think well
i better stop looking at that and start
doing it every day as you look at
pictures somebody working from home
socializing looking after their body
horse riding
hiking
making salads as you look at it enough
you become inspired
to take action it motivates you it
inspires you it fills up your mind with
what you want
and it fills you up with a desire a
passion
it motivates you conditions you programs
you compels you to go after what you
want
it holds you accountable
and it's so easy
so don't make it perfect i am a powerful
manifesto
you have to meet the vibration
you can't be above or below it it's just
what i was talking about negative energy
positive energy in order to draw the
thing to you that you want to come you
can't want it so much that you fear that
you won't get it you have to want it so
in order for me to be on your vision
board you must have put it there and
then you let it go yes and then you
weren't thinking about it every day
every day every day because you can't it
doesn't come to you that way you have to
do it and you have to put it and then
you have to meet that vibration you
prepare yourself to be there and ready
if you're caught and thinking negatively
about the world and about yourself this
is so important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me is part of the secret to the
law of attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form sometimes
we manifest things far beyond our
wildest dreams so sometimes if we have a
vision of something it happens in a far
greater way so we want to stay open yep
so we can say i want that macbook air
but maybe we get that macbook air that's
a little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequencies we've done a lot of work
we've cleaned up a lot of our own crap
we believe in ourselves today and that
that energy of believing in ourselves
has attracted us together today and
brought us into this space where we
together are co-creating and teaching if
i hadn't cleaned up my side of the
street and if i didn't believe in myself
the way i do i would never have
manifested being on marietv miracles
occur naturally and when they're not
occurring something has gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our
anxiety our anger towards the past that
future tripping and projecting all of
that energy gets in the way of allowing
all of the miracles to occur naturally
the first type of manifestation is to
get very very clear you must be clear
because if you are unclear you'll start
to call in some things that are not
really what you want you'll be confused
uh the other piece is that once you're
clear you can also then get clear about
all the ways that you don't believe most
people never manifest their ideas
because you don't trust your ideas that
bold idea that came to you that made
sense to you in the moment the next day
feels too bold too crazy too insane to
not for someone like you i believe that
the decisions that come to you when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you and you have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way and talks you
down from doing the things that you
should be doing so right now i'm in the
process of looking for a creative
director for my business someone to look
at all my content suggest ways to make
it better to to
be focused on the branding and
opportunities for me and this was a
suggestion from mark drager friend of
the channel a long time personal friend
of mine as well he helped film my very
first video he's the reason why i did
top ten moves to success
long story with mark and he said evan
you need a creative director for your
business creative director or brand
manager or ceo somebody to be in charge
of all the creative decisions
and getting me out on the stages that
they need to be out on so how do we make
these videos better that's that person's
role and so in my head
when he first said it i'm i'm a little
afraid i'm scared like
how do i find this person i need to vibe
well with them i don't i can't just
bring anybody into that role i'm a
pretty weird duck and so this has to be
a good you know long-term fit for me how
much is this person going to cost how do
i fit into my cost structure right now
with my business how are we going to
deal with conflicts it's all of the
negativity all of the things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on this is a
bold idea and i need to at least explore
it i need to try i need to play it out
maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
teaching yourself teaching myself that i
do bold things i do scary things i do
difficult things and being scared is not
a good enough reason for not to take
action and so those ideas that come to
you trust that they came to you for a
reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man i
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan plan you're
going to spend all your best energies
just stuck in planning mode instead of
actually going out and taking action
you're going to tell your friends about
it they're going to tell you it's a
stupid idea you're going to sleep on it
you're going to wake up and tell
yourself it's a stupid idea and then
what happens is no momentum the biggest
thing that is missing from your life
is momentum
nina's happy and just smiling she's next
to me filming that's always missing
you're a genius you have great ideas
great genius amazing ideas you're just
missing momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself why you
can't do it instead of going off and
proving to yourself that you can so how
do you find the ideas and then how do
you take action on them i'm going to
give you a three-step process step
number one is go for a walk have a
shower do whatever the thing is that
makes you feel energized creative and in
the zone right if you're constantly just
in front of your phone and stressed out
all day long you're not going to come up
with creative ideas so where do you get
creative ideas i get creative ideas when
i'm driving i get creative ideas when
i'm in the shower i get creative ideas
when i'm walking i don't really meditate
so i don't get ideas when i'm doing that
but it's it's time when there's nothing
scheduled and so do you have enough time
during your week or during your day that
is open that you allow yourself to think
and be creative
for a lot of people watching this you
probably do you probably have some
moments in your calendar that are
dedicated to at least having a shower
hopefully hopefully you have showers on
a regular basis right so you're coming
up with ideas right so whatever that
thing is that lets you come up with
ideas do more of it right if you get
great ideas in the shower maybe instead
of a five-minute shower take a 15-minute
shower maybe you get some more ideas
coming to you right you want to you want
to spend more time doing the work that
generates creativity for you that's step
number one step number two is don't
judge the ideas that come to you this is
where so many people fall down you get
an idea and then you judge it and you
say i can't do that i'm not good enough
i don't have the money i know the
connections i didn't go to school for
that i'm not tall enough i'm not pretty
enough i'm not smart enough whatever
people like me don't do this thing all
these ideas why you can't win you're
telling yourself why you can't win
before you even started
don't judge the idea trust that the idea
came to you for a reason so if i'm
thinking about somebody
in the shower somebody that maybe i met
yesterday or somebody that i haven't
talked to in three years
why am i thinking about that person uh
i don't know
italians have this expression they go
book means i don't know
so i trust that idea came for a reason
that idea is flowing through me for a
reason and i gotta do something about it
and so whenever i'm thinking about
somebody in the shower the next thing is
i get out of the shower and i'll email
that person right away and i'll always
make it awkward and say hey i was
thinking about you in the shower today
and then tell them what the story was
and it's never backfired on me
it's never backfired on me
sometimes it leads to some great
opportunity and sometimes it goes
nowhere but you get the idea you do
something get the idea you do something
stop judging the idea stop telling
yourself why you can't do it and then
step number three is take immediate
action and build momentum again the
biggest thing that you're just missing
is momentum you're a genius you're an
amazing entrepreneur you've got tons of
potential sarah blakely had this idea to
create spanx and it made her billionaire
when everybody thought she was crazy
right i'm sure you have ideas like that
too what's the difference between you
and her momentum
she did more she started she took the no
she took the rejection she took the
fears and she said i'm gonna give it my
shot you need to build immediate
momentum as soon as you get that idea
whether it's in the shower on the walk
on the drive whatever it is as soon as
you get that you're not allowed to leave
that moment that moment of courage that
won't have boldness a moment of feeling
unstoppable that moment like i can do
this when you're feeling that moment
you're not allowed to leave it without
having done something immediate action
every single time and sometimes that
leads to something great and maybe the
momentum falls off the next day that's
okay but in the moment
you have to take immediate action no
more excuses stop letting yourself off
the hook stop telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it and go show
yourself that you can i once heard a
definition of health that made a lot of
sense to me
good health it said is having no fatigue
having a good appetite
going to sleep and awakening easily
having a good memory
having good humor
and having precision in thought and
action
not being klutzy
being honest
humble
grateful and loving
how healthy are you
i do not heal anyone
the work i do is to help people
understand how their own mental patterns
are constantly creating their own life
experiences
all of them
the good experiences
and the so-called bad experiences
and also
how these same mental patterns
are contributing to the ease
and dis-ease
in their bodies
we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every disease we have
it is the body's way of telling us
that we have a false idea in
consciousness
our body is telling us
we are on the wrong track
and need to change the way we think
every illness
is a lesson
for us to learn
please do not just complain i want to
get rid of this condition
it will not create the healing you want
nor will you learn the lesson you need
to learn
this is not a time for condemnation
or for creating more guilt
we are just looking at what needs to be
released
this is a time for healing
for making our lives and our bodies
whole
i know
you have within you all that you need to
accomplish this
once we begin to understand this process
we are able to take conscious control
of the changes we wish to make in our
lives
this is a very exciting process
and becomes one of the most important
adventures in our lives
i believe there is a center of wisdom
within each one of us
and when we are ready to make positive
changes in our lives
we attract whatever we need to help us
something inside of you has shifted
and the healing process has already
begun
you might even say that to yourself now
i have already begun
the healing process
the body like everything else in life
is a mirror of our inner thoughts and
beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen
every cell
responds to every single thought you
think
and every word you speak
continuous modes of thinking and
speaking
produce body behaviors and postures and
eases or diseases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face
did not produce that by having joyous
loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of inner
dialogue
how will you look when you are elderly
you see it is my belief
that it is our birthright to be totally
healthy
and totally fulfilled
in every area of our lives take a nice
deep breath
and if possible
allow yourself to be in a comfortable
position
just let these ideas wash over you
only those ideas that are right for you
will be accepted by you
it doesn't matter whether you understand
them all or not or if they make sense to
you right now
your subconscious mind will hear and
record whatever you need
i believe that all illness is
self-created
not that we say i want to have this
illness
but we create a mental atmosphere where
this dis-ease can grow and flourish
our internal mental dialogue reacts in
every cell
in the body
i heard a physician say recently
if the surgeon operates on a patient
without doing something to help them
change the cause of the disease
then all the doctor is doing is
prolonging the life of the patient
until the patient can create another
disease
you see we need to do more than just
treat the symptom
we need to eliminate the cause of the
dis-ease
and for that we need to go within
ourselves where the process of illness
began
it is my belief that we are each
responsible for every experience in our
lives
the best and the worst
we all create our experiences by the
thoughts we think and the words we speak
the universe totally supports our
internal dialogue
our subconscious mind accepts as truth
whatever we choose to believe
you can say it either way
they both mean that what i believe about
myself and about life becomes true for
me
what you choose to think about yourself
and about life becomes true for you
everything is possible you know when you
believe
that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief creates our entire life
experience
and so you can't
if i put it this way you can't
experience anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs if
we can't experience anything that's
outside of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really because
we're all experiencing a world based on
our beliefs and not one of us has the
same beliefs not one of us so that means
there's a different world for every one
of us
so
all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind
which is actually higher than the
conscious mind and so we use our
conscious mind with all of the thoughts
and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right
and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what
is really what creates if i want to make
it really really simple then i would say
your subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear
and manifest things
and that's where all of your beliefs are
stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something
and your subconscious mind creates
everything
so you can see it's all kind of
perfectly designed
um so now to manifest you have to
believe
and
you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want and
the reason that you have to believe you
have it already is because the
subconscious mind
is only operating in the present
it can't reason it's just like a program
so if you say
for example
um
a new car is coming my new car is coming
i'm going to get a new car it's coming
well then it's always going to be coming
right that's the that's the thing you
have to imagine you have it now
you have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car
and just then
visualize being in that car
and then when you do that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
is manifestations instantaneous
so
so
the other ways to believe is to affirm
over and over and over um
so
to be really repetitive for example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful
because when we close our eyes and we
put ourselves in the picture and you
must make sure you're in the picture
and you put yourself in the picture with
whatever it is that you want and you
close your eyes and you just kind of
create this mini movie
honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea
it just sees that movie and recreates it
it's like a giant photocopying machine
it will just whatever you hold in your
mind it will
photocopy it warm into the world
so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if
and um for example
if you wanted to attract the perfect
partner
are you acting as if your perfect
partner is here already and so there are
just small things that you can do that
are super super powerful for example are
you sleeping in the middle of your bed
or are you sleeping on one side of the
bed because your partner's on the other
side of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes
is there room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partners here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it
and your perfect partner will be
attracted to you through the most
incredible circumstances so
if something hasn't manifested yet and
you really really want it
and i i doubt there's anybody out there
who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right i mean
um i'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it you can't feel the
emotion of your future
your manifestation of love before it's
made manifest like people say well well
my relationship hat when i find mr right
then i'm going to feel love waiting for
the outer environment to change
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness
but they forgot that they create reality
in other words when it finally appears
that i'm going to feel love that's
that's cause and effect we're waiting
for something to happen if you're
feeling the lack and the emptiness
then you're keeping your relationship at
arm's length because you don't have the
magnetic field to draw to you
so
the emotions that come from these energy
centers the lower energy centers in our
body do have frequencies there's
chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person
can you teach
your body emotionally
what the future will feel like before
it's made manifest that means you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you have to reverse that battleship and
understand feeling love now is going to
be the magnet and if you can hold the
vision of your future a clear intention
with a coherent brain
organize signals into the field
and you could actually crack this thing
open and
practice
getting so present in the moment
that you're not anticipating the next
moment or trying to predict the future
and you're no longer romancing the
emotions of your past you can find that
sweet spot of the generous present
moment the familiar past is the known
emotionally the predictable future is
the habituation of autopilot being
unconscious and programs those are both
knowns there's only one place where the
unknown exists that's the present moment
so if you could work with your body
to the point that it trusts you enough
to feel so safe
that you have conquered it in a certain
way that it could actually relax into
the present moment and it's not worried
about what's going to happen next or
what's going on around around you or
that you need to eat you need to pee you
need to move you've got beyond all your
drives and you're you're ready to create
that moment where you're present
if you could begin to work with your
heart
and start to breathe and start to
practice feeling love in the beginning
it would feel foolish or gratitude why
would i feel love if it hasn't happened
well that's because you've been
hypnotized into waiting for your world
to change to feel feel the emotion from
the experience
but according to the quantum model
your emotion ahead of the experience
when you combine that clear intention
with the elevated emotion
and you feel love your body's so
objective
that it's actually believing it's living
in that future in the present moment and
your body now is beginning to change you
are beginning to change your biology to
reflect
what you're about to experience in your
future
so the stronger the
love you feel the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you're going to
pay attention to that picture in your
mind stimulus response memory emotion
thought and feeling but now you're
remembering your future if you're truly
in the present moment and you know
exactly what you want
and you
begin to teach your body emotion start
practicing opening that heart it's
amazing what happens
the moment that heart begins to open
we've measured this so many times lewis
on a on a scan on a real-time brain scan
when the heart moves into this kind of
rhythm when you're feeling
frustration
when you're feeling impatient when
you're feeling resentment you are
stepping on the gas pedal and you're
stepping on the brake at the same time
and the heart is pumping against the
closed system and it causes an erratic
beat it becomes incoherent and energy
literally leaves the heart now you no
longer believe in your future you can't
put your heart into your future you
can't trust the outcome because there's
no energy there it's it's being used and
consumed somewhere else so energy is
leaving the brain as well
but once energy starts to move into the
heart we've seen this so many times and
it starts to beat in this rhythm like
banging a drum or dropping a pebble in
water pebble after pebble the heart
begins to create a wave of energy right
to the brain like like taking a big
sheet
and going like that and then all of a
sudden you see this wave and the brain
gets this rush of energy and that change
in brain wave patterns that change that
wave is carrying information
and the person starts to get a very
clear idea they see their future very
clearly now now that energy is causing
them to move into very coherent alpha
brainwave patterns which is the state of
creation this is when you no longer hear
the voice in your head that's talking to
you that you listen to and believe is
the truth i'm not good enough yeah
whatever it is
it suppresses the default mode network
and the next thing you know
you start seeing in pictures and images
you start dreaming
and that's the imagination that's the
creative state so now you start
naturally imagining the is the creative
center we got to put our heart into our
future it better be open and activated
so now when you start falling in love
with your future
oxytocin is released in the brain and in
the heart oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide signals another chemical
called endothelial derived relaxing
factor and just like when your sexual
organs get filled with blood because
you're aroused the same thing happens
here as it would happen somewhere else
and literally the arteries in the heart
and lungs engorge and now your heart
feels full and it's thumping in order
and you're
in the present moment now once that
happens and it's beating in rhythm the
heart produces an external magnetic
field up to three meters wide now
you're in survival you're drawing from
the field and turning into chemistry
when you get energy in the heart it's
causing a change in the brain
and all of a sudden it's resetting the
baseline for trauma
and now here you have a magnetic field
now the heart
is your magnet it is it is the center of
creation and now that that energy is
frequency
and frequency carries information and
you can lay the thought of your new
relationship life is a series of changes
those of us who are rigid and inflexible
in our thinking
often snap when the winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily
and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly the
negative thoughts for what they are and
i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences i am unlimited in my own
ability to create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive
life brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world my life has
always worked perfectly only i did not
know it i didn't realize that every
negative event in my world was life
reflecting back to me my belief system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn
i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love light and
joy
all is well in my world
i open new doors to
life as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have and i know
fresh new experiences are always ahead
of me i greet the new with open arms i
trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind
if you give your power to others then
you have none when you claim your power
it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience there is no way you can be
prosperous if your thinking is
impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited source
in an unlimited way i am blessed beyond
my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief i
am mentally and emotionally equipped to
enjoy a prosperous and loving life
it is my birthright to deserve all good
i claim my good now
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you
it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well someone said
to us one day when we were trying to get
them to focus upon positive things and
we sort of laid out a list of positive
things that she might think about and
she said oh abraham i don't want those
i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then
you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought and
law of attraction is helping you to
sustain
the pattern of thought that you have a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others sometimes it
came because of something that you
observed and then talked about and then
remembered and then attracted again and
then talked about it and then remembered
and then attracted again in other words
life is very interesting here isn't it
because you can't talk about anything
for very long before it begins to
replicate itself in your life experience
and it's what makes you develop your
patterns of what you call truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure and then i
pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience
and we say that's really wonderful isn't
it if it's stuff you want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this
sort of mass consciousness theory that
goes like this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say
the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it the
more law of attraction matches you up
with it the more you're living it the
more you're talking about it the more
you're beating the drum of it the more
you're offering the vibration of it this
gathering we're calling it the art of
allowing but what it really means is the
art of telling a different story the art
of telling the story the way life has
helped you carve it out incrementally
but telling the story
with your words with your observations
with your expectations with your
vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing
are there things in your life that are
as you want them to be
keep telling that story
are the things in your life that are not
as you want it to be
don't tell that story
you cannot choose something that feels
better until you are aware of what you
are choosing
so
relief is the order of business what do
you want to talk about in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans
said we have been led to believe that
the universe is a great machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard con henry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is immaterial
it's mental and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part
and the reality about it why is that and
so important as uh sad vijay had just
mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard khan henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world
and then i give you the science that
says there are two minds that are
operating at the same time one is called
the conscious mind and one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so
the subconscious mind is not thinking
creating a subconscious mind push the
button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind
we are connecting our spirituality to
the biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science is recognized 95 of the day
because we are thinking 95 of the day
our behavior is now controlled by the
subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see
is the consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have and
then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was so just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens now talking about
paradigms is another subject we'll do
that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white type thon the paradigm
will kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
and another lesson i'm going to show you
how to change the paradigm when you
change the paradigm the change in
results is automatic you know why you
start to attract something new something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information and
eliminate the negative
i'm going to show you how to do that
a law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good
we're in a negative vibration you want
to feel good move into a positive
vibration stop and think of what you're
grateful for
but understand this
you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the paradigm get you on that frequency
tantra means the technology
technology means
when those times when we did not have
any external instruments of technology
we realized the highest grade of
technologies here
and to exercise this
in many different ways
now
if we want to see outside the door
we need a periscope
now somebody found a way to look beyond
without a periscope
using your mind
beyond the realm of your body right now
mind is functioning within the realm of
your body you want to use it there it is
possible to do that it's not not
possible
it's just that
all kinds of wild and observed things
are believed if you trim those things
in many ways knowingly or unknowingly
many of you are using this
you create what you want in the world
when you really want it
in a way it's simply your focus which
makes those things happen
maybe it is not as
tangible as it's in a cinema
but
every one of you to some extent you're
doing isn't it
how effectively do you do it
depends on uh
there are many things if i say
things that happen around me
they're too fairly tailish
i wouldn't believe such nonsense if
anybody told me so i won't tell you
because i don't want you to believe or
disbelieve those things but every day
people around me witness things which
they think is nothing short of a miracle
but there's no miracle
life is a big miracle
are you a part of it or are you out of
it that's a big question question is are
you consciously in it
or are you out of it that's a big
question
if you're in it
you're see if you use any thought
this is uh well he was asking how do we
do it in the beginning
suppose you generate a thought
have you noticed this suppose you
generate a thought
and then you invest your emotion in this
thought suddenly the thought becomes
boom
yes or no
right now i generate a thought oh she's
such a wonderful person
but now i invest my emotion into the
thought now suddenly
you are not just another person to me
you are something else to me
is it reality or no
just because you invested your emotion
into your thought
now there is a next thing
if you invest your life energies into it
consciously
suddenly this will become something else
altogether
suddenly you become like
life is a play
is no more a struggle
because
miracles are always happening you put a
little seed it becomes a tree he eats a
noodle he becomes a man
i'm saying this is happening to
it's happening all the time just see you
put filth into the root just see it
becomes fragrance
is it is this not miracles and miracles
all over the place
the question is only
are you consciously a part of this
miraculous creation many people come to
me and say i want to be a millionaire i
i and there's a great song about i'm
going to be a millionaire and they read
things like the secret which says if you
want to be a millionaire just just wish
it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school i
was going to be a nanny that's how much
i thought i could earn in my lifetime
that's what i thought i was meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help
the more reasons you will have to become
and stay a millionaire
and here's the third thing and this is
so important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
with my sofa and manifest millions if
you want a job you go out and look for a
job if you want a new home you go out
and visit new homes
you want a partner you better go out and
put yourself in front of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hairdryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way
it's not about shall i invent something
i don't have an inventive mind are not
creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a multi
multi-million dollar company they didn't
invent a new product well they sort of
did they took an existing product they
made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti and money will fall from the
heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mark and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success of course they can take time out
but you see when you do what you love
and love what you do it never really
feels like work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day
meeting deadlines i travel all over the
world through time zones giving talks
and sometimes that's tiring i plan out
my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template and i'm going to
follow that template and if you have the
belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire money is the exchange of
values
in fact the way a society spends
money
is
a clue
to their values so right now most
wealthy nations and even some unwealthy
nations poor nations are spending money
on weapons on mechanized death
on drugs
on alcohol
on gambling
on
sleazy stuff
and that only represents the collective
consciousness
of
bad money bad karma
and um
therefore
stay away
from
any
way that
generates money
through harm
and this is what uh
the great teacher of all time
uh the buddha he said
right livelihood so right livelihood is
that kind of livelihood
that creates
joy in the world that
increases abundance in the world
increases
and improves the quality of life in the
world
okay
understand that when you're exchanging
money you're exchanging values there's a
clear separation between awareness and
the mind we're not the mind rather we're
awareness moving through different areas
of the mind right so this is the most
important thing that i can share with
you and this is really the core
uh it is the foundation of everything
that i do teach so once you realize that
you're not the mind but rather that you
that rather that your awareness moving
through different areas of mind you can
control where your awareness goes
and now i want to bring your attention
to another point this is a saying that
my guru said many many decades ago where
awareness goes energy flows right and
you've heard me share this many times as
well online
so once you know
that you're not the mind rather than
your awareness and if you can control
where your awareness goes you can
control where your energy is flowing now
let's look at energy energy is like
water right whatever it is your water
will start to grow energy works the same
thing in the same way too whatever it is
you put energy into will start to
manifest in your life so if you put
energy into something negative it'll
grow and manifest in your life you put
energy into something positive it'll
grow and manifest in your life
one thing you want to do is move your
awareness there as you move your
awareness to those goals that's where
your energy is flowing as your energy
flows there you they start to manifest
in your life but one of the things you
want to do is to be mindful and be very
conscious of where you're spending your
energy you only have so much energy each
day right
so you want to really assess your life
and look at the people and things in
your life and say okay i've only got
this much energy how can i take this
finite amount of energy that i have
and proportionately divide it into these
people and things
in my life that i care about so that i
can start to manifest them remember what
manifests in your life is
proportionately
is in proportion to what how much energy
that you're actually investing into
something so if you want something to
manifest in your life put energy into it
how do you put your energy into it you
move your awareness to that thing and
when you move your awareness there where
awareness goes energy flows
and that thing starts to manifest in
your life three things to keep in mind
purpose
focus simplify have a clear purpose
clear goals
focus on those things right focus on
those purposes and those goals
throughout the year always bring your
awareness back to them and simplify your
life simplify your life to the most
important people and the most important
things in your life so that you can take
the finite amount of energy
that you have and invest it into those
people and things into your into your
goals your energy dictates your results
think about it when you have felt
positive motivated energized ready to go
courageous bold you show up differently
right you show up differently than when
you're feeling depressed that it's not
going to work out
the negative self-talk someone like you
can't do it you're not getting any
momentum you're not getting the results
like think about your own mental state
when you are
[Music]
trying to accomplish a goal
and the difference between when you have
positive energy versus negative energy
it has nothing to do with your skills
has nothing to do with your potential it
has everything to do with how you're
feeling right now
right it's why i say that lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you don't believe in yourself enough you
don't have the right energy level and so
you don't go off and create even though
you've got it inside you to do it and
you've got the heart and the mission and
the care and the love and you want to do
it
it's all about changing your energy
states i think there's a misconception
that people who are high achievers wake
up and just feel energized and motivated
ready to go right today i did not wake
up and say yes
come on
let's go take on the dare i'm so excited
right that's not how i woke up today i
woke up it was dark outside it's snowing
as you can you can tell here right it's
snowing look at look at what look at
what nina's driving through
stay safe nina
both of our safety depends on it
she's driving through the the snow storm
it's dark outside
and i wake up and and the difference is
i don't i don't put my feet on the
ground to get all jazzed up and start
yelling about what a great day it's
going to be i wake up but i'm tired and
i'm like why is it so dark outside
why we have this snowstorm uh you know
i'm thinking about the call i had
yesterday with brendon burchard on zoom
and he's showing me his
tropical
puerto rican beach backdrop and i got
canadian snow happening here right now
the difference is
the people who you admire who have the
success who are the high achievers they
don't wake up like they're a superhuman
and extra motivated
they're just like you the difference is
they have the habits and the routines
where they demand the energy from
themselves they create the energy for
themselves and so
there's there's two things that i want
you to start thinking about how do you
do it right like okay great heaven how
do i do it how do i actually change my
energy how do i get it so that i am
feeling powerful bold motivated
confident excited on a daily basis
because it is possible and because you
know how great you feel and you know the
results that you get when you're feeling
that way
so two things that i want you to keep in
mind the first one is
having
something in your morning routine that
demands that from you so for me music is
the fastest way to change my state music
i have a playlist called the believe
playlist
it's hashtag believe all caps on my main
channel you can go find it that's the
music i listen to every day that may not
be the thing that gets you fired up but
it is for me
music is the fastest way to change your
state because there are some songs that
when they come on when you hear them
it just makes you want to move you might
get up and dance you might just be nod
in your head you might be tapping your
foot but there are some songs that come
on that make you want to move it can't
just be the same song every day because
then you're going to get sick of it and
bored of it but you make a playlist of
the different music that when it comes
on
it forces you to shift your state
we often put on the music for how we
currently feel so when you're sad and
low and depressed or upset you put on
music that makes you feel
reinforced and you're sad and low and
depressed and upset states
when you're sad and low you don't put on
music to make you feel better you put on
music to keep you where you are that's
the problem that that then what it keeps
you where you are
right when you put on the music for how
you currently feel it keeps you where
you are where what you want to do is use
music to shift your state so when you're
feeling not so motivated when you're
feeling tired when you're feeling low
you put on music that gets you up and
what's going to happen you're going to
feel a little bit more up so putting
that as a part of your daily routine
daily daily daily daily daily daily
daily daily daily daily daily daily
it matters it makes a difference if you
if you started your day with music that
would make you feel
energized pumped up motivated ready to
go if you started your day with that
your day will look different your days
will look different your weeks will then
look different your months will look
different and the things that you
accomplish will look dramatically
different okay so that's a daily basis i
need you to shift your morning routine
to incorporate something like that just
try it try for a week and see how you
feel it'll make a difference i promise
step number two is
reacting to the moment so that's what we
do in step number one is what we do on a
daily basis in the morning step number
two is when we have something that
we come across
that
makes us feel less confident that makes
us feel scared that is a big opportunity
that makes us question ourselves doubt
ourselves when you look at your calendar
you look at your emails you look at the
results and you see that you're not
where you want to be
the tendency is to beat ourselves up the
tendency is to play scared the tendency
is to act small the tendency is to
procrastinate and go do something else
right you know i've been there you've
been there maybe you are there right now
you know what i'm talking about
energy is now the reason why we're
staying where we are so how do we shift
our energy
in those moments
one remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things
that if it's hard that if it's scary
that it's difficult you're going to do
it you're going to do it you're going to
show up you're going to do it because
you do difficult things
it cuts the brain out of the equation
because now it's time to show yourself
what you can do
instead of overthinking over
procrastinating
and being overly scared because you made
it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you're special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want some law of
attraction hacks with dr joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there when i get my new
car i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen